11 000 tons of wheat arrived in lebanon
this week but this will be the last
shipment from ukraine the world's key
wheat producers russia and ukraine are
at war lebanon like other countries in
the middle east and north africa can no
longer rely on them for most of their
imports they're now trying to make up
for an expected shortage
we've reached out to a number of
countries including the us india canada
and some european countries which
produce the soft wheat we need for our
bread
but the problem is not just finding
alternative sources diversifying
supplies could mean transportation
delays or an increase in shipping costs
wheat prices have already hit a 14-year
high
definitely we will resort to more
expensive countries that export wheat
which would sell to us at prices that
are not as cheap as in russia and
ukraine so if the conflict is prolonged
and supply is less this will add
pressure on balance of payments or the
budget
egypt for example is one of the largest
importers of wheat in the world and 80
percent of its supply is from ukraine
and russia
it is considering raising the price of
bread for the first time in three
decades it's no different in lebanon
where authorities warn the central bank
may not be able to subsidize bread if
prices continued to rise the tunisian
government which is believed to be
running out of money has been rationing
flour and reduced bread production
increase in prices will affect millions
of people in the middle east and north
africa who live in poverty
the ukrainian russian war will affect
import export and trade because we are
all importers of wheat and most of the
foodstuffs are from abroad
across this region economies have been
hit by inflation and large public debts
others have been destroyed by war syria
no longer produces enough wheat to feed
its population so it relies on imports
and is now rationing wheat the world
food program says 12 million syrians are
food insecure while yemen is on the
brink of famine yemen for example where
16 million people
require food assistance and the world
food program is assisting 13
million of them this country is almost
entirely dependent on food imports and
depends on imports of wheat from russia
from ukraine sorry by about 30 percent
so any uh shock any slight shock would
actually send these countries into a
very very serious food crisis
food prices are at their highest level
so is poverty in a region already in
turmoil and where higher bred prices
have led to popular anger in the past
senator al jazeera